currently driving through very windy
mountainous roads to try to get to the
Village of a young man that we met in
the previous Village
to help bring supplies back that Spanish
volunteers given him so we're taking him
there he tells us his village has been
completely destroyed so these villagers
have set up camp at the foot of their
destroyed Village nobody has any
intention of leaving here
um it's so remote that Aid isn't getting
here in terms of being delivered
so basically what they're doing is
walking to Villages that are more
accessible or using donkeys and uh
bringing it here
you can see the hospitality of them even
in times of tragedy are offering us
tea and nuts
so we're being taken into the village
this is a community that depended on
agriculture
they're telling us everything
has gone
this Village
buried eight people they're a village of
seventy
and the destruction is uh
it's immense
this is where I lived with my parents my
mother was in that room that's where she
died along with my wife
and to think that this is one of
countless villagers in the middle of
nowhere hard to get to
how are they going to rebuild it
we've just bumped into this gentleman
who tells us this is uh
this is his home up there
okay I'm hurt here and I'm hurt here
obviously we need to rebuild all of this
but that's only possible if health comes
it's hard to remove all of this
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera telephone in
the Atlas Mountains of Morocco
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera